Encuentra la pendiente de la función lineal
definida por la tabla,
y nos dan esta tabla de aquí.
En la tabla hay unos periodos laborales
y nos dicen cuantas horas duran estos periodos
laborales, por ejemplo mediodía son 4 horas
y un día completo son 8 y también nos dicen
cuanto dinero se gana en cada uno de estos periodos.
Digamos, si se trabajan 4 horas se ganan 54 pesos, por 8 se ganan 108 pesos y así sucesivamente.
Y luego también nos preguntan,
¿qué representa la pendiente en esta situación?
Así que hay que decir cual es el valor de
la pendiente y darle un significado.
Repasando brevemente, la pendiente es igual al cambio en la variable de pendiente,
dividido entre el cambio en la variable independiente.
En este ejemplo, con la información de la
tabla, la variable dependiente, es la cantidad
de dinero que ganamos, puesto que depende
del número de horas que trabajemos.
Como es costumbre, denotamos a la variable
dependiente por "x" y a la variable independiente por "y".
Así que nuestra pendiente se convierte
en el cambio en "y"...
cambio en "y" dividido
entre el cambio en "x"... cambio en "x".
Bien, entonces, la pregunta es,
¿cuánto cambia la cantidad de dinero que
gano, al cambiar al cantidad de horas que trabajo?
Para responder esta pregunta, voy a tomar
la información de la tabla.
Voy a tomar dos filas distintas y voy
a comparar sus valores.
Digamos que pasé de trabajar 4 a 8 horas...
de 4 a 8 horas,
entonces mi cambio en "x"es la diferencia de 8 y 4,
o sea, 8 menos 4, así que esto es mi cambio en "x".
En realidad me pude haber tomado cualesquiera
dos filas de la tabla,
pero las cuentas hubieran sido más complicadas.
Bien, y para este cambio en "x",
¿cuál es mi cambio en "y"?
Pues ahora pasé de ganar 54 pesos a ganar 108 pesos,
así que el cambio en "y", la diferencia
entre el dinero que voy a ganar y el dinero que ganaba,
es de 108 menos 54, así que bueno,
Así que ¿cuál fue el cambio en la variable dependiente?
Fue de 108 menos 54, que es simplemente 54
y, ¿cuánto es el cambio en la variable independiente?
Pues es 8 menos 4, que es 4.
De modo que si trabajo 4 horas más,
gano 54 pesos adicionales...
¡Ay! aquí se me había olvidad el igual.
¿Y cuánto es 54 entre 4?
Lo haré acá arriba,
54 dividido entre 4 es... creo que voy a usar puntos decimales... 4 cabe en 5 una vez, así que 1 por 4 es 4,
5 menos 4 es 1 y bajo el 4,
4 cabe en 14 tres veces, 3 por cuatro es 12
y ahora 14 menos 12 es 2, bajo este 0 y 4
cabe en 20 cinco veces, subo el punto decimal,
5 por 4 es 20 y ya no me queda ningún residuo.
Así que esto nos da 13.5
y como estamos hablando de dinero,
igual y es mejor decir, 13.50.
Y para las unidades solo hay que considerar pesos que son las unidades del numerador,
dividido entre horas, que son las
unidades del denominador.
Con esto ya podemos a la pregunta de
¿qué significa la pendiente en esta situación?
La pendiente sencillamente nos dice
cuánto se gana por hora,
cual es el salario por hora
de trabajar en este lugar.
Y siendo sinceros, realmente no teníamos
que tomar dos filas distintas y compararlas,
podríamos haber simplemente dividido la cantidad
de dinero que ganábamos entre el número
de horas que trabajábamos.
Por ejemplo, si trabajamos 8 horas,
ganamos 108 pesos, así que 108 dividido entre 8,
nos da 13.50, así que no había necesidad
de comparar dos filas, pero al menos así
ya aprendimos algo de pendiente.